today we're gonna talk about the seven
benefits of taking a cold shower
this is really about something called
cryotherapy cold therapy now with
cryotherapy you're put into a crowd
chamber for just a very small amount of
time because it's a very very cold
two maybe three maybe up to five minutes
and this concept is really based on this
word hormesis okay hora mucins what is
that that is a situation where you're
adding a low dose dress or a moderate
amount of stress to create a beneficial
effect there's a lot of things that can
create this effect this is called
hormetic effect but it's really a
survival mechanism that's been around
for eons I mean if you think about in
the past with human bodies the
combination of how many times that our
bodies have starved and been in the cold
so you're freezing and starving and what
the body will do over time to adapt it's
really built within our genes so just by
taking a 20 minute cold shower it can
increase norepinephrine by two to three
hundred percent and when you increase
this neurotransmitter which is made by
your adrenal glands and other parts of
your body you can really drop
inflammation you can increase your
antioxidant networks including
glutathione so your ability to detox
protect against DNA damage is improved
also your mitochondria increase as far
as the numbers of mitochondria you can
generate more energy which is
fascinating so taking a cold shower of a
period of time can actually boost your
energy also your T cells increase these
are the cells that help you prevent
against infection against viruses and
even bacteria now you would think by
going into the cold you would get sick
but you're only going in the cold for a
certain period of time when you do a
cold shower I always recommend start off
with maybe 30 seconds for a minute and
gradually increase it over time and then
maybe turn it on to a hot shower and
alternate just because pain tends to be
very painful so you want to gradually
ease into it
if here's some of the benefits of a cold
shower it decreases muscle pain
and anytime you have an acute injury you
want to use cold and not heat that's
just a side down
you also get decreased joint pain joint
inflammation especially with rheumatoid
arthritis you'll speed up recovery from
either a workout or you had an actual
injury from sports eg it decreases
inflammation in general increases your
cognitive function your overall mood
there's been some interesting studies on
depression and anxiety and also it can
even increase your metabolism now I know
the last way people want to lose weight
is by taking cold showers but it can
boost your metabolism a little bit but
of course you want to be on keto and
intermittent fasting to really do it
correctly anyway these are the benefits
and comment below if you have ever used
cold as a therapy thanks for watching
hey if you haven't already subscribed
press the button below and I will keep
you in the know
hey that runs